tu as connu tu as tout minutes tu dois
devoir désigner cinq spectateurs qui
selon toi porte des élèves attention
c'est parti
trois attaques basses bourg et ses coûts
ça va sûrement me déjà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai su ça merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si tu prends le père de gypse et c'est
pas le bon allez-y tout cas ça marche
cadastre à ce niveau ou tard ils avaient
dit qu'ils avaient aidé à les vérifier a
tancé le rectorat lorette toi il en
restera là je te tire les 45 secondes
pour trouver le dernier 47 secondes
beaucoup à l'avant dernier en tout cas
il y avait une vérité trop beau si j'ai
pas le monsieur l'arabie attendait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
derrière les nababs la bénéficie d'un
petit fils ya des femmes tiennent un peu
fatigués ou qu'ils apprécient peut-être
à la guinée qu'on attend pas vas-y
m'écoute l'actrice je suis motard est
mort
[Musique]
également commencé à monter chez vous
sachez le en fait les facs et isabelle
la régie me dit il en fait les oubliés
baincthun 5
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]